there's a new report out which finds
that young women are trending liberal
and that young men are not trending more
liberal the hill has a piece 44 of young
women counted themselves liberal in 2021
compared to 25 percent of young men
according to Gallup the gender gap is
the largest recorded in 24 years of
polling the finding culminates years of
rising liberalism among women ages 18 to
29 with no increase in their male peers
the article notes quote several societal
forces have conspired to push young
women to the left including the metoo
movement former president Trump Rising
lgbtq identification and most recently
abortion policy slow cooking Trends in
marital status and educational
attainment have also nudged the needle
there's another aspect to this all of
that is true
there is a ton of nonsense about
masculinity
out there that I believe is impacting
the number of men willing to say that
they are on the left now I think some of
them are on the left but are unwilling
to say it but that's difficult to
actually prove so we can even keep it
outside of this discussion that's just
an opinion that I hold
um and it's it's based merely on
anecdotes I think there are some much
like for a time when you know lots of
times you hear there's more gay people
now than ever well are there more gay
people or is it that gay folks on
average are more open to saying that
that's how they identify whereas in the
past they were not for different
societal pressures I think right now
there is a societal pressure
particularly among without a doubt the
right wing and even among the center
where men have been convinced that there
is a lack of masculinity in Progressive
beliefs that there's a lack of
masculinity in to some degree empathy
you look at you look at silly little
things like the electric vehicle thing
we recently talked about Marjorie Taylor
green suggesting that Pete bootage's
supportive electric vehicles is somehow
um feminine that that it's emasculating
to for a man to drive an electric
vehicle and of course there it was
homophobic Buddha judge is gay and it
was all mixed up with this homophobia
that is
um just a a big thing for Marjorie
Taylor green
um you know thing also people to judge
being an involved Dad when Pete Buddha
judge and his Husband
um had twins Pete bootage took paternity
leave and he was widely ridiculed by the
right Lauren bobert even saying what is
he chest feeding that's a quote is he
chest feeding and again the idea that
gay man paternity leave well it must be
somehow feminine well he's just being a
good dad that's all it is
um and so I I believe that that's a
factor as well and sadly
some of these sort of Guru type figures
that are predominantly appealing to
those on the right
um although Jordan Peterson appeals to
many on the left as well I'll be totally
upfront about that
although it may not be explicit from
Jordan Peterson
he puts together
a pretty clearly defined kind of
archetype for masculinity
that doesn't really include the types of
empathetic
sensitive Progressive beliefs and
perspectives that
um quite frankly have nothing to do with
masculinity so I think there's a lot
going on here and it is not surprising
that we see in terms of overt
identification young women identifying
more to the left
but not young men now then there's that
other X Factor and it's are some of
these young men actually Progressive but
they don't say it
because of that very same societal
pressure and I don't know the answer to
that I someone who knows more about
research methods might be able to say
well here's how you could study where
there is a sort of reticent
progressivism among some young men let
me know your thoughts I don't think this
is particularly good if I'm passing some
kind of a moral evaluation of it I don't
think it's a particularly good thing for
society let me know your thoughts find
me on Twitter at dpacman and if we get
some interesting feedback we'll do a
follow-up
one of our sponsors today is BusyBox
child I know that there are many parents
in our audience this is for you BusyBox
child offers really great subscription
boxes for kids filled with sensory toys
that will help your toddler to
Elementary age child stay off screens
and do some really interesting stuff
technology used by kids is at an
all-time high especially after the
pandemic playing off of screens is
really critical for development for
cognitive development social emotional
well-being for kids it's an ideal
opportunity for parents to engage with
kids as well Carolyn is the founder of
busy box child she's a mom and a child
clinical psychologist who designs all
the boxes that you receive busy box
child offers monthly sensory kits with
different themes for each season or you
can get a monthly sand bin subscription
for hours and hours of fun check out
their mini jars and mini kits for
playtime on the go BusyBox child is a
small business that supports the David
Pacman show support them go to
busyboxchild.com and use the code Pacman
for 10 off the link is down below